and we are calling it
iPhone the iPhone has always had an
Infamous mute switch ever since the
original model and now it's being
confirmed that apple is getting rid of
it finally after over 16 years and I
know some of you hate that news but
don't worry because it's going to be a
lot better than you think so in this
video I'm gonna dig deep into these
brand new leaked cads shared To Us by
shrimp Apple Pro on Twitter but first I
do want to go through some other leaks
that were just released now I know last
week ice Universe released some
groundbreaking news that the iPhone 15
Pro Max will have the smallest or
thinnest bezels out of any phone ever
breaking the current record of 1.81
millimeters on the xiaomi 13. now it's
going to be 1.55 on the brand new 15 Pro
Max we even saw the actual cover glass
and a leak right here showing how
incredibly thin it is and just today a
Sony Dixon showed off the comparison
between the regular models and the new
15 Pro Max right here you can see how
thin it is on these two models on the
right insanely thin compared to a bit
thicker on the left which I believe this
is going to be the bezel on the regular
iPhone 15 model similar to the 14 pro
right now but the main thing you are
here for is this new button and the
important piece of news is that you can
see it right here it no longer switches
back and forth however the regular
iPhone 15 model is going to continue
having the old mute switch as you can
see in these cads right here for the
regular 15 so the Pro Models are gonna
get that exclusively so now let's jump
into this actual video and just taking a
look at them as you can see right here
in this video we got the new redesign
with the flat sides that have a curve
going into the glass 2.5 D glass which
is going to be awesome and right here
you can see that buttons sticking out
right here on the side right next to the
new volume rocker button yes that
confirms that on the Pro Models we will
no longer have a volume up and down
button it'll be one long kind of rocker
style Button as you can see and Ming
Chico has already confirmed that it will
no longer have a volume button that's
physical yes it's going to be solid
state just like touch ID is right now as
well as this trackpad which doesn't
physically move it just has a vibration
motor behind it to make it seem like a
click so the new 15 Pro Models will
actually have three different taptic
engines the main one that it already has
right now and then two more one for the
volume rocker side and one for the power
button side because all of that is no
longer going to be physical but as far
as this brand new mute button you can
see that it's no longer a switch that
moves side to side it's gonna be an
actual button that you can click so this
basically confirms that after 16 long
years we are not having a switch anymore
this is by far the biggest redesign to
that mute switcher button ever now of
course this is going to disappoint quite
a few of you including myself because I
love switching it back and forth It's
just so addictive and it feels awesome
to feel that haptic motor but I think
apple is going to be doing something
great with that new button I believe
that it is going to be acting just like
the Apple watch ultra's action button
that we have right now which can be
programmable to a bunch of different
tasks or apps I think apple is bringing
the action button to the iPhone right
where the mute switch used to be so
you're going to be able to click it once
maybe even click and hold to do some
kind of other action or some kind of
other app you could use it to open maybe
your camera app or some other app that
you program because right now some
people just leave it on mute and don't
touch it they just leave it there it's
just sitting there as kind of a wasted
button so why not turn it into a
programmable action button I think that
would be a genius move from Apple to do
now the only issue with this new leak is
that unknowns 21 has said that his
sources say this is a fake render so
they took issue with the apparent lack
of detail in the port area now if you
didn't already know unknowns 21 was the
one who leaked the official real image
of an iPhone 15 Pro with titanium being
used as you can see right here and of
course USBC however thankfully Ian zelbo
did come out and say that case cads have
always looked like that where they kind
of lack detail because they don't really
have to have specific detail if it's
just for cases and of course we do know
that Ian zelbo works on a lot of renders
and he's very very detailed he's
actually working on these awesome
renders of the 15 Pro Models with insane
amounts of detail so he should know what
he's talking about and once again right
here in Ian's render you can see how
that new redesigned Edge merges with the
glass panel just like it does on the
Apple watch that's going to look amazing
but either way if Apple does give us a
new programmable action button instead
of the mute switch I think a lot of
people are going to be very very happy
and keep in mind this is not coming to
the regular iPhone 15. that's going to
keep the old switch so it's going to
make more and more people want to
upgrade to the Pro Models finally I want
to finish off with some leaks of the a17
bionic chip we have about 3019 points
for single thread or single core which
is much more realistic compared to the
leaks that I leaked previously which a
lot of people said were fake sorry about
that if they are this looks to be more
realistic and this multi-thread score is
also really really good almost as fast
as an M1 MacBook Air in your pocket in
your iPhone and now as far as pricing
for the the new iPhone 15 lineup with
that new redesign and USBC the
manufacturing costs are rumored to be
around 21 higher than the iPhone 14
series and that of course is going to
come to that new design or things like
the Pro Models getting an improved lidar
scanner and all the other changes that
are coming like the titanium metal the
extra Ram like for example getting eight
gigabytes finally on the pro model we
needed that because sometimes apps still
do close down so that is going to be a
big help also the fact that we're
getting new more efficient OLED displays
across the entire lineup that's going to
help them not heat up as much where the
new iPhone 14 pro that we have right now
that does a much better job than before
but it does still sometimes overheat and
dim down so that is going to be a
welcome help but the one I'm really
excited for is the Periscope lens coming
to the iPhone 15 Pro Max model that is
going to be awesome because it's going
to give you from about 3x to 6X Optical
lens Zoom at least according to Ming
shikwo which he is actually very very
accurate so now we're finally gonna have
much better Zoom shots on an iPhone you
can see how it works right here you
basically have an internal piece of
glass or many lenses that kind of
bounces off of a mirror so it gives you
extra range like up to 6X Optical that
is going to be amazing that's going to
make them more expensive and because of
that I do believe that the Pro Models at
least will be getting a price jump of
about a hundred dollars maybe even more
but a hundred sounds pretty good to me
I'm not sure about the regular iPhone 15
models but maybe we see a jump by maybe
50 bucks something like that but it is
going to be more expensive in my opinion
and I think it's actually going to be
worth it with those changes especially
with an action button so hopefully you
enjoyed this video and if you did let me
know down in the comment section below
and click the circle button subscribe
for more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]